[Music]
every game needs a face dragon playtime
there goes altering a kill force ego
gets both supports and the goal of the
sea swoops in an ambassador to lift it
from the screen and give it the kind of
intrinsic value that makes us fall in
love
excellent man well thank you very much
for your time and we're going to send it
back to the DES right now when overwatch
was in its infancy its faithful
followers needed somewhere to go to keep
their overwatch famished eyes satisfied
and they found that in a bird
[Applause]
this is the story of that bird who
became professional over watches first
hero this is the story of seagull
[Music]
Branden seagull Larned has had a journey
through eSports fit for a bird an avian
voyage that soars through multiple games
a foray into the world of twitch the
bright lights of the overwatch League
stage and then right back to the comfort
of his streaming setup seagulls journey
started with Team Fortress 2 joining
classic mix up in 2013 as a demo man and
roaming soldier competing with the team
in three major events that year the
biggest cash prize since the CGS the
biggest cash prize in our game in five
years unbelievable tf2 is often heralded
as a major influence for overwatch and
these kinds of class based shooters ask
a lot from their top performers you've
got to have the aim game sense and
precision of a Counter Strike pro all
while mastering a number of unique
characters and kits a seagull was
playing with classic mix up the era of
moments was fully underway and
counter-strike was the shooter of choice
for eSports fans but at Blizzcon 2014
Blizzard announced their modern-day
iteration of the class based shooter
overwatch and unlike any game that had
come before it it was specifically
designed to facilitate competitive
gameplay so my friends get a load of
this we hope you love it like we do I'll
see you on the other side
[Music]
Siegel's popularity outside the tf2
scene began to rise with the official
release of overwatch on May 24th 2016 he
immediately started to play the game at
a high level and identified characters
that matched his tf2 skillset while
adapting to the more complex mobis style
abilities that were present in overwatch
I really really wanted to become a pro
gamer in any way that could where that
was streaming whether I was competing no
matter what I wanted to build something
for myself and the biggest thing that I
found about it was I could sit there and
I could learn the game and I could teach
it to other people and then you realize
you actually have so many more people
who care about you just you as a person
outside of the pro scene with his foray
into overwatch fully underway Seagal
wasted no time jumping right into twitch
where fans were hungry for top-2 your
gameplay
[Music]
[Music]
got'em Siegel was a computer science
major at Washington State University
when his dream first started to blow up
and it was actually his parents who
suggested he take a break from school in
order to give full-time gaming a chance
early in the overwatch game Siegel was
the community's poster boy people
immediately fell in love with the game
but nobody knew how long it would take
for the overwatch league to come
together so they found comfort and
watching a bird shoot some guns
please from the very beginning there was
only one way to describe seagulls on
stream and public personality lovable he
then became a member of team luminosity
right as all the major eSports
organizations started signing over
launch rosters during the early days of
overwatch it was clear that the yearn
for eSports was there but players like
Segal were relegated to third party
events anyway $22,000 up for grabs here
potentially in this next game $15,000
the first $7,000 to second and biggest
just one game away from the biggest
price person overwatch history late in
2016 overwatch started to grow and
attract larger prize pools Segal was
picked up by NRG esports and qualified
for the 2016 overwatch World Cup with
Team USA during this time Segal also
competed at APEC season one Apex was
often looked at by fans as a way of
predicting what the overwatch league
would eventually look like because it
featured a mix of players from all over
the world and everyone wanted to know if
players like Segal would be able to
stack up against Korea's best again but
Seto comes in with the Deathwatch Anna
Luz
on dual RV while everybody gets caught
up in that graviton search and they cut
diving in there has a lot of damage
built up on that Zarya Sego gets three
here we go
coming in that's graviton surge used by
both teams actually some barrier as well
energy has that shield and they're going
to use it to carry themselves through
this teamfight starting out strong
Seefeldt looking for more victims takes
out doyoung looks like this is gonna be
a point I take for energy looks like
sound barrier coming through just in
time but the blizzards passing just long
enough for energy to push up me back and
they get the point that's the match the
ant energy takes a three oh the
competitive scene was revving its
engines and seagull was quickly becoming
a recognizable face within a relatively
faceless eSport as is true with other
competitive endeavors like sports it's
being clear since the very beginning of
eSports that someone celebrity can be as
important to their brand as their skill
level and with overwatch in its infancy
the hype surrounding the game was more
about the much heralded overwatch League
and the game itself not the people
playing it but Seagal was one of the few
exceptions to that rule maybe the single
most important moment in seagulls rise
to overwatch in a variety was one simple
handshake or rather a lack thereof
here's a guy who goes by the name of
Seagal finishing up an interview at a
competition this week and check out his
cool handshake at the end watch
excellent man well thank you very much
for your time and we're going to sit it
back to the death right now
hey in case you missed it let's get a
closer look at that hatchet that's it
[Applause]
with one outstretched hand at the
overwatch open met by maybe a little
more resistance than expected Seagal
became the lovable goof we know today
and his overwatch game was only getting
better as 2017 began all eyes in
competitive overwatch were on overwatch
contenders season 1 the overwatch League
had officially been announced and
players were scrambling to show off
their skills in order to land a coveted
spot on one of the league's franchise
teams but in the bridge period between
the game's launch and contenders
overwatch kind of stagnated and its
players like Seagal who helped the game
stay relevant on Twitch by giving fans
something to watch while the overwatch
League started its rollout as contender
started Seagal left energy and joined
team envyus
in September 2017 envious for one of the
top North American teams during the
contender's era and with the oval watch
league's first season on the horizon
Seagal had separated himself as one of
the best projectile players in the game
that title contenders acted as a kind of
proving ground many eSports
organizations fielded teams and for
players like Segal it was the place to
show off his skills before rosters were
finalized around this same time
organizations were purchasing their
spots in season one of the overwatch
League and team envyus was one of the 10
organizations to do just that it was
finally time for Segal to test his
skills on the game's biggest stage as
one of the faces of the team envyus
operated Dallas fuel not gonna see any
big hero swaps coming here no Reinhart
stores get bragging playtime there goes
altering a kill force ego gets both
supports and the goal of the sea swoops
in sea go right now trying to loop all
the way on the side old kids kooky and
jail what a long-range rockets five-year
in touted targets junior going to get
resurrected but they are surrounded
right now seagull
search use early dragon strike septum
straight through there they have the
combo available didn't need to use it
even gets Rockets and body at the end
okay for a lot of over watches top
players the first stage of the oval
watch League was the scenes ultimate
proving ground with the exception of
Apex most overwatch events had been
regional but o WL featured a mixture of
the most highly touted players from all
over the world so for players like
Seagal and his teammates tae Moo and xqc
it was time to show that they could hang
with the best Korea had to offer a feat
Western players had long been chasing
across eSports and that is its old
dynasty we'll take it - oh here on
illios good opportunity for London they
only need that first tick to win the map
and those are the kills ever looking for
that's gonna be in London Spitfire will
take the 3-1 victory over Dallas feel
applying it putting the icing on the
victory cake here for NY excel I think
that's gonna be it
it's just token with the primal rage and
he's not going to be enough New York
well win three to one to say that the
fuel and seagulls initial attempt at
overcoming the insurgents of Korean
talent during the early days of o WL was
a failure would be an understatement
they finished stage one with a three and
seven record while they watched Korean
dominated super teams like the New York
Excelsior and London Spitfire style
under the bright lights that trend
continued into stage two where they went
two and eight after that time period
pretty much coaching / management Lost's
all faith in me is how I put it I don't
think I played in a scrim for probably
four weeks by that weight I was just
over three weeks so transition had
happened they moved on without me
is the TLDR rate the Dallas fuels start
to their time in the overwatch League
was just about as underwhelming as
possible and Siegel's role on the team
and future were filled with question
marks but he would persevere somehow
Seagal was able to completely overhaul
his overwatch game
deeming ly overnight a career damage
dealer across multiple games honed into
a tank player all to keep his dreams
alive I was told over team dinner that
they were going to be signing rascal and
so essentially they didn't have a new
solid role for me that I was okay with
and I knew that we needed a second off
tank player in case Mickey was sick so
I'm ahead I'm going okay well we only
have one diva player so I'm gonna go
learn diva pretty much told them that I
was going to go learn diva because I
think that had a better value to the
team and playing just like third string
EPS by that point but despite his
stellar transition the fuel did not
improve on their performance in stage
three where they went one and nine the
pine falls on point B every sixty six
and your team wins anyway there's a big
seller I don't think it does it look at
that you see the primal rage use just to
stay alive and on the payload and why
that's it he's gonna jump in wants to go
for the widow who realizes he's got to
touch the card oh you got Bonnie just
healing right now but yeah you now that
you have cool Matt back it is gonna be a
quick death therefore OGE
all the chained heels going through cool
Matt even going for the self destruct
over and a hard defeat here for the
Dallas feel huge to outlaws they reign
supreme in Texas the fuel possess some
of the most beloved and recognizable
faces in the game but they couldn't put
up the results their fans and the
community expected and unlike during
apex and contenders where he was a
highly sought after Western talent
Seagal was a replaceable level player
compared to the rest of the OWS
talent when we lost our morale it was
definitely low from losing but in a
certain way it was it was still okay
like we was just a temporary low and
everyone was kind of hard on themselves
in a certain way it's one thing to get
outplayed it's one thing for the
opponent just to play better than you
want a certain day it's another thing to
fall apart and that's what happened but
as the league's fourth stage got
underway something extraordinary was
happening trying to get that rally
a shadow burn both dead there will be a
self-destruct road but it's not gonna
matter in this game you could revive the
clay pigeons Noah will save two strikes
extravaganza right here apparently a lot
of people said it tank heavy metis going
to favor the fuel true they run Mickey
on the brick Itza they run Siegel on the
diva now the fruits of their labor for
having Siegel practice so much off tank
this season now it's coming back as a
boon to the fuel sure but the player to
help him get it done is Siegel I think
he has been so strong recently when you
look at his diva play he's at the top of
the charts for everything offensive he
can play the Genji he could play the
hand so the junk random Farah and he can
have great performances all over the
place and of course there you go the
short the season perhaps Siegel was
flying again and the Dallas fuel were
headed to the playoffs he went from
playing Genji and Farah to having the
best stats in the entire league with
Deva in stage four but as their
semi-final match against the league's
most feared team in the New York
Excelsior began the fuel looked
outmatched mono and Mecca are just in on
every single pill 30 prelims and we
already have Internet going in with the
trance nobody else is gonna die here for
New York Segal you're the last one
uncle's trying to float his way back
into the fight but it's not meant to be
a New York excels they're running away
with the text to make all be for naught
unless Siegel and og can go to town on
this oh Siegel he's coming up with two
but that might be it oh gee the last man
alive here at nobody close enough Harry
hook going for the foul trying to fly
his way back into this fight but they
will not make it in time it is gonna be
two ticks and a second map picked up
your Excel taking the lead in this best
of five series in classic Cinderella
fashion the fuel were not about to go
down without a fight the bubble here is
about to back up as long as that bubble
survives they may be able to hang in
here just a little while longer trying
to get on Sanibel try to remove that
healing out of a tight spot it is either
point just long enough for a Dallas fuel
to find the victory upset with a - OH
complete with keeps Dallas fuel alive at
the semi final great I mean they'll say
there'll be no hesitation honest I know
the tumble chill from Siegel on Cadman
the stylish self-destruct again with the
passive plays donut car clip are all
dead that's gonna send - you're packing
and should be able to get back Beco
maybe touch he gets bashed away again no
one can touch
comes through again and stops Dallas
fuel making it exciting let's go to map
number five so unfortunately this
Cinderella story doesn't have a happy
ending
[Applause]
self-destruct out I'm gonna find a kill
they're still on top of this without
their proportion we're gonna actually
deny it Vicky will be the one to contend
finally somebody here for the Dallas
fuel that allows for timer to get out on
to the point as well
Harry hook try to play the angles just
trying to stay alive try to get the heal
[Applause]
over Dallas and New York excelsior slay
the Dallas tree David did everything he
could to match Goliath but in the end
the New York excelsior defeated the
Dallas fuel in a grueling five-game
series and then Seagal left the nest
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
upon completion of the stage for
playoffs Siegel announced that he would
not be returning to play with the Dallas
fuel for the overwatch league second
season chat it's not a debate we're
gonna have a talk chat I I kept lying to
myself for like two years like over and
over again I would sit there and I would
be like oh yeah I can do pro and I can
stream at the same time it'll be fine
just think about being a professional
player and you realize that every single
day that you're trying to go pro someone
who used to be a part of the stream that
you built is leaving and if you focus on
Pro play you're letting down your stream
and if you focus and if you try and
bounce both you're letting down your
teammates who are your second family
there's no winning as has become a trend
with popular streamers of late seagull
left his professional team to pursue
full-time streaming
seagull began as one of the most popular
personalities in the game as a streamer
the peak of his popularity as we now
know was in Korea where he inspired tons
of his viewers to take up the game those
same Korean players who eventually
supplanted him in the overwatch League
boomers are getting the shivers Lou hi
Maggie
toe toe toe to toe how much buzz on a
faulty da-da-ding da-da-ding in a mosque
Segal lived the eSports dream and in the
end it all came back to twitch
since overwatch is beginnings Segal has
been one of the game's most popular
streamers and when he returned to
streaming full-time nothing had changed
okay hi milk dogs hi mom the cookie no
no I'm just some dick dick he brings
something a little different to the
table than your average top streamer to
be frank about it he's just a really
nice guy now that's not to say that
other top streamers aren't nice but
Segal has found a way to wield it
he's not wild or dramatic or toxic
he's just wholesome and laid-back which
makes him extremely likeable since his
departure from Dallas Siegel's dream has
seen a boost in numbers during August of
2018 his first full month as a streamer
since his overwatch League career
started he averaged more than 14,000
viewers at a time that's a large jump
from his time balancing his pro career
where he averaged just under 9,000
viewers at a time in June and July in
addition to his jump in average views
Segal also had his metaphorical
coming-out party on August 28th when he
peaked at more than 107 thousand viewers
the overwatch had its cosmetic promotion
called twitch drops targeting Segal that
day and fans quite literally flocked to
his stream I know most here for the
sprays chat did I make it did I do it do
we pick another kid oh my god that's
awesome even Jeff captain secure thank
you I love you chat thank you for being
here this is insane just thank you so
much with this stream Seagal cemented
himself as the undisputed king of
streaming overwatch his journey back
into streaming was immediately validated
and as one of the most lovable faces on
Twitch the overwatch community
celebrated him overwatch is still a very
fast game and that can make it difficult
to stream at times while communicating
with your community recently Seagal has
tried streaming games like Call of Duty
blackout and fortnight to some success
[Music]
Oh [ __ ] run but he's never come
anywhere close to his twitch drop
numbers on stream The Seagull story is
something we're starting to become quite
familiar with in the gaming world and it
wasn't that long ago when we saw shroud
retire to pursue his career as a
full-time streamer and now we've got one
of the most popular na overwatch pros
doing the same thing so this begs the
question our eSports starting to become
just the beginning is streaming really
the end goal if your dream is to spend
your days playing video games or will
these two career paths continue to
operate adjacent to one another Seagal
is trying to prove that this trend will
continue the bird is taking flight for
the top of the twitch rankings and only
time will tell if he'll reach his
destination thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]